la parole est à madame catherine vautrin
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
simplement rappeler notre collègue
vice-présidente que la campagne
électorale coxon n'autorise pas tout
qu'on n'utilise pas les drames que
connaît notre pays
les victimes pour de la démagogie
électorale et je crois qu'il est
important de réaffirmer notre soutien à
toutes les forces de sécurité dans la
diversité
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre est les français voient
avec espoir et soulagement ce
quinquennat s'achevait à l'heure du
bilan nous nous souvenons tous de la
campagne présidentielle de 2012
comment oublier l'anaphore du candidat
hollande qui énumérait doctement ce
qu'il renierait quelques semaines plus
tard lui président s'est vue contesté
publiquement par son premier ministre
aujourd'hui candidat à sa succession lui
président a demandé à voir la cour de
cassation sous l'autorité directe du
premier ministre a gravement insulté
juges et magistrats
sans s'excuser publiquement lui
président a troqué son exemplarité
contre une vie privée étalée dans la
presse et les librairies lui président a
reculé sur les réformes
institutionnelles
incapable de tenir sa majorité à
l'assemblée nationale et la perdre en
haute sénat lui président a gonflé
immodérément son gouvernement inventant
des ministères sans attributions lui
président a vu plusieurs ministres en
difficulté avec la justice honte à
menacer de prison ferme lui président
dévoyer le statut d'élu local créant des
parlementaires hors sol
toujours plus proche des parties
toujours plus loin des français lui
président a piétiné les partenaires
sociaux avec la loi adoptée la loi
travail adoptée avec le 49-3 lui
président a été inaudible lorsqu'on
voulait l'entendre et assourdissant
quand la réserve s'impose et met lui va
réussir un pari recaser ses amis de la
france d'en haut socialiste ancien
ministre élu membre de cabinet
et on les retrouve dans les ambassades
et caisse des dépôts la cour des comptes
les directeurs d'hôpitaux gustave roussy
lice l'hydra ratp rt institutions
culturelles universités merxheim madame
votre âme la parole est à monsieur le
premier ministre
[Applaudissements]
madame la députée catherine vautrin
je dois reconnaître que pour la première
fois depuis que je suis ministre j'ai du
mal à trouver la réponse à votre
question parce que je vois dans votre
question tellement de sujets polémiques
mais les les uns aux autres avec une
volonté d'atteindre la personne du
président de la république que je me dis
que entre la question telle que vous la
posez et la conception que je me fais de
l'action publique du débat public et du
respect que l'on se doit les uns aux
autres au monstre pays doit affronter
des échéances électorales
il y à vraiment madame la députée je
vous le dis très sincèrement entre vous
et moi en raison de la conception que
j'ai de l'action publique
un abîme on peut bien entendu madame la
députée
au moment où nous sommes dans une
situation électorale se mettre à user de
toutes les caricatures convoquer toutes
les outrances essayé de porter atteinte
personnellement à l'adversaire plutôt
que de s'en tenir aux projets aux idées
à la réalité mais je veux vous le dire
très nettement madame la députée sur ce
sujet comme ceux qui vocifèrent avec
vous nous vous laisserons seuls sur ce
chemin parce que ce n'est pas ce que les
français attendent d'une grande
démocratie et ce n'est pas la dignité
qu'appelle le débat dans un contexte
comme celui et confrontent auxquels est
confronté notre pays
alors laissez-moi vous dire un certain
nombre de choses que vous n'avez sans
doute pas esprits et si vous ne les avez
pas l'esprit c'est sans doute parce que
vous préférez la polémique à la réalité
et je vais en quelques mots me contenter
de vous rappeler la réalité lorsque vous
étiez en situation de responsabilité
les déficits était absolument à bissau
nous avons trouvé à déficit budgétaire
au moment où nous sommes arrivés en
situation de responsabilité de plus de
5%
nous serons le prochain à 2,9 pour cent
nous sommes donc le gouvernement
qui sur les comptes publics sur les
comptes sociaux or auraient aura
contribué à rétablir une situation
extrêmement dégradée que vous nous aviez
laissées et dont vous ne parlez pas
parce que vous êtes tout à fait légitime
à être gênés par cela et avoir au du
débat que du du bilan que vous nous avez
les gays nous avons en quelques années
rétabli les marges des entreprises
feraient près de 40 milliards d'euros
d'allègements de charges pour rétablir
la compétitivité des entreprises
nous avons augmenté l'investissement
industriel de 3 4% cette année
ce qui est bien le signe d'ailleurs que
nous sommes dans une situation de
reprise économique et nous avons
retrouvé les marges des entreprises qui
existait en 2008 alors que sous le
gouvernement que vous souteniez le
chômage avait explosé 750 mille emplois
industriels avaient été détruits dans le
cadre d'ailleurs d'une politique fiscale
qui visait à faire payer toujours plus
ceux qui sont les plus défavorisés pour
protéger les plus riches des français
d'ailleurs vous n'avez pas changé
puisque c'est exactement le programme du
candidat que vous soutenez à l'élection
présidentielle nous avons rétabli les
services publics en donnant au service
public de sécurité des moyens dont vous
les aviez privé treize mille emplois
nous en créerons une zone euro créé 9000
nous avons re donner des moyens aux
forces de sécurité en augmentant
l'investissement dans les matériels dont
ils ont besoin pour faire face au
terrorisme
vous avez diminué de 20% des
investissements dont avaient besoin les
forces de sécurité nous aurons recréer
60 mille emplois dans l'éducation
nationale
là où vous en avez détruit 80 milles
nous aurons recréer les conditions de la
formation des enseignants pour que
l'égalité des chances soit une réalité
nous aurons créé les universités
d'excellence nous autres et 500 millions
d'euros de bourse supplémentaire
tout cela vous ne voulez pas en parler
vous préférez la victime vous préférez
lente agonise à sion du pays
vous préférez les polémiques inutiles et
bien face à cela ce gouvernement et la
majorité seront dans la dignité d'un
débat qui appelle la vérité et qui
appelle aussi que sur les sujets nous
parlions de ce que les français
attendent de nous
[Applaudissements]
merci